it's a region plagued by political
conflict and economic crises the
international monetary fund says 141
million people in Arab countries are
hungry and at nearly 30 percent they
have the world's highest levels of use
unemployment the region also faces a
humanitarian crisis internal conflicts
have created the largest number of
refugees and displaced people in the
world while suffering acutely from
climate change temperatures have soared
and water is scarce against this
backdrop Arab leaders will be meeting in
the Algerian capital for their annual
Summit the first since the pandemic
began three years ago since then there
have been geopolitical changes
the Arab world has long been divided but
the decision by some countries to sign
the so-called Abraham Accords and
normalize relations with Israel shifted
Dynamics if you consider that Palestine
was always really at the heart of the
Arab League and what it stood for this
new alignment of states with Israel
potentially against Palestine is
something that is certainly
transformational the other issue has
been obviously the Ukraine war as of
late which had a massive impact on
obviously energy markets on Supply
chains
the impact is being felt by the lower
income countries where societies are
struggling with Rising food and energy
prices the Ukrainian War has also had an
impact on the politicians calculations
the desire not to be drawn into the
conflict between Russia and the West
does seem to be something that all
countries in the region share so they
are looking to insulate the region to
the extent that they can from being
drawn into what might become a new Cold
War Arab leaders are engaged in the
tensions between the East and West among
them Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman he has been under U.S pressure
due to a decision by OPEC plus to reduce
oil output Washington believes that
works for Russia's benefits whether a
unanimous stance and statement comes out
first of all in support of Saudi Arabia
second of all in support of Arab
neutrality away from the current Russian
Ukrainian War because this if it happens
will empower the Saudi political
decision and the pushback against
Washington's pressure Arab Summits have
had few if any impactful resolutions due
to Regional differences but this time
around the challenges as a result of
international developments may affect
the outcome Algiers